I stumbled on this community of people
on Twitter that are called 100
percenters that are still basically
stuck in 2020 and this woman had posted
a picture of her bed and it was a tent
in her garage with the HEPA air filter
in the door and she's like I've stopped
talking to my husband because he's not
taking the same precautions as I am I
need data points on this how many of
these people are disgruntled spouses
yeah oh god oh he's not taking the
precautions again yeah yeah yeah geez
I'm going to the tent
oh you went outside ew I'm gonna die
yeah yeah what are you doing the guys in
there just sad posting on Reddit man my
wife she's a hundred percent or she
won't talk to me I'm trying to rekindle
a relationship yeah he's like getting
motivation periodically knocking on the
garage door trying to talk to her babe I
think we could work this out says
[__] Wilson in there yeah
the [__] volleyball the wig and that
[__] and she's out there with her new
man like [__] walking through a
casino in Vegas cheaping cigarettes with
her new man